Wyatt Russell is an actor he's an
overlord it's in theaters now he's
getting great reviews for that you can
also stream the first season of lodge 49
on demand and on AMC premiere and he
joins us now in the man cave I think he
might be the first guest we've had who's
come in with flip-flops on but come on
up come on up why does he make swag good
to see you bud
good to see you he's the son of a Kurt
Russell and Goldie Hawn oh I'm sure he
you don't get tired of hearing that do
you know yeah never yeah this is my
favorite show on television I'm serious
really yeah because okay so every
morning I wake up and I'm a routine I
like my routine you know I get my coffee
take the dogs out and I put on the show
to me this is like I think my dream job
I think you guys have it it's about
who's role would you want though you got
McLovin fritzy Seaton Paulie are you
going for the best share here Thanks I
everyday it changes but you know look
I'd want to be I'd want to be you damn
you're gonna go for the throne I want to
go for the throne I mean I have to work
my way up from the bottom okay yeah
but yeah I'll go I'm going for the
throne not your throne my own and some
weird little web webisode world maybe
one day well you played hockey so you
have to go into the juniors you have to
go into the minors all of those things
she went to Europe yeah I did all that
it was the world's greatest experience
I'd never changed it for anything I got
hurt when I was 25 24 couldn't play
anymore really happy that happened would
you if you didn't get hurt would you
have gone into acting no no I wouldn't
have
I probably would have because if I
wouldn't have gotten hurt that means
you're ending at 34 35 minutes and and
at that point like what are my
marketable skills not hockey
so I don't have I didn't I was really
happy that when it happened
i I I was young enough to go I'll jump
with two feet and not think about
anything I'm getting to worry about I
got no anxieties I got no responsibility
I'll just do it I didn't hockey and I
thought like if it worked at work and if
it does and it doesn't
but what did your parents say when you
say I you know I want to be a
professional goalie they wool well when
I first started playing goal my dad did
not want me to play goal he was like do
not play goalie please don't play goal
just go and have fun and you're gonna be
a baseball player anyway so it doesn't
matter like you're gonna be a catcher
you're gonna hit you know 2:17 you're
gonna be in the big leagues like that
was is that was his thing because my
whole family were baseball players i I
just didn't like it as much so when I
said I really really really wanted to
play goal and he realized I was serious
about it there was a guy here named
Constantine Laden yahu was he's from the
Ukraine and he played on he played on
the Red Army he came over in the 90s
when the Wall fell and in van nuys as a
ring called Iceland it's like the worst
place you've ever been in your entire
life we used to get dressed in in a in a
trailer like a tractor trailer yeah and
and the ice rink I'm not kidding his
butt as big as this room and he would
slash and hit like you know stick
between your legs and like in the groin
and yeah in the in the bet in the bad
area while you're getting like slap
shots at you and he would take I was ten
yeah when I was ten years old because
because point being was that like first
we had he had social services called on
a kit on us while we were practicing by
another mom and my dad was there with
like nononono no wait this is your
Southern California in 1996-97 and like
hockey wasn't a big thing then here now
it is now it's hockey actually pretty a
big big sport and yeah it reasonably saw
and but she they didn't understand that
like no when you go and you want to play
hockey like you you're getting bad
things we're going to
and you're gonna have to learn how to
play through them and that was
Constantinian was great at that and he
you know he he was he was a big part of
my life
best hockey movie of all time got a slap
shot it's gotta be relate to any of that
oh my god are you kidding me
every I mean every character every
aspect of every piece of I mean even to
the point where I mean for me it was way
crazier in some respects where when I
went to Holland they they you're on the
phone with your agent and they go I'll
go anywhere I'll go I was playing hockey
in Germany at the time and I just wanted
to like get a job somewhere so they call
me and say you got a you got a team and
groaning and wants you to play okay
great you're out you're on a plane the
next day so I get groaning and it's
exactly what I expected it's Europe and
there's cobblestone streets and there's
like a ship in the back that like sells
pancakes I was like this is awesome this
is exactly what I want and I walk up the
stairs and I'm they've put me in a drug
den that's from living and you're like
right this is minor professional sports
abused to it the guy who's my roommate
comes in the it sad it's truly a drug
down because harm he's my roommate
invites me up for dinner and I'm like
I'll go to the Attic and harm will cook
me sausage and potatoes and it's my
first night and and I get up there and
he's room is like covered in newspaper
it's all in Dutch and he's got this cat
running around and Frank who's a Rwandan
refugee is also my other roommate in the
Attic and I'm like I'm not sure if
what's legal and what's not and the cat
as we're eating the sausage and potatoes
burro wasn't his name
it probably harms about probably 70 and
looks about 115 and and the cat jumps on
me and he gets his he gets his nails in
me and I'm like God look and I pull the
cat off and he goes he starts losing
mind it's guys not to him like whoa stop
go easy and and then he stops he picks
up a bobby pin because he stabs him with
a bobby pin and he's dragging his arm
down the bobby pin and he picks up a rag
to pick it up and I see all of his drug
paraphernalia underneath this rag and
I'm like where am i what did I do like
what this is insane and then you decide
to get into acting yeah that was my
first but that that was what was great
about it you know that was what was
great about professional sports before
the way I love the guy he became a
friend of mine and you know he was a
great guy
but it was it was that was the kind of
experiences that you can't get anywhere
else that was why you'll never change it
you know he's white Russell the actor
Overlord
is in theaters now also the first season
of Lodge 49 on demand and on AMC
premiere I ran into Adam Sandler last
night Sandler goes you're having Wyatt
on I said yeah he goes I bought yes
you're your parents house yes yes so
that was across the suite Goldie Hawn
and Kurt Russell lived across the street
from each other and then they got
married is that how this works and then
Sandler bought never married that
they're never married okay they're not
married very proudly not married okay
they we moved to Vancouver we moved out
of our house I'm moving I was 15 to
Vancouver to play hockey they didn't
want to move lose that part of my life
they lived there for a year and a half
when they did they sold their bigger
home they got a smaller house across the
street there was actually my my brother
and my bike best friend Jon stahlberg's
then they lived in that house for a
while Sandler bought the house from them
okay when we moved so that we became
like next-door neighbors no yeah he's a
great dude
yes I got I got something to say about
the Aaron Rodgers thing okay oh all
right all right here's a hot take hot
tape this is how you audition for my job
thank you okay there are two positions
in sports that matter as much as the
other one of them is a quarterback and
the other is a goalie because because a
goaltender can act
they steal you games yes you can
actually win a game they you can Jayesh
sugar almost one literally
single-handedly won that the anti um
ducks that championship and like Oh for
I think it was and and the same thing
with a quarterback you have the ball in
your hands every single play and the
attitude that comes from the quarterback
is unbelievably almost as important
sometimes I would argue as what you can
do with the football because I'm a big a
Broncos fan Tim Tebow changed the
organization in my opinion he took what
who is the the quarterback before Tebow
that you came in the guy that was like
he never Orden
Zordon Kyle Halloran he was fine you
know but he couldn't make something
happen he couldn't make magic happen Tim
Tebow was intrigued make magic happen
and made an organization believe in
winning they made him believe in victory
even though it was like everyone was
laughing at it and then they kicked him
to the curb and brought in peyton
manning but without that season i argue
you go what three and fourteen thirteen
or whatever Tim Tebow somehow managed
every game I remember watching be like
how is this happening and this magic
surrounding this football team you bring
in Peyton Manning after they've won a
super playoff game and then they go win
a Super Bowl a couple years later and I
argue it's because of Josh position and
how that person is and I think you know
that Aaron Rodgers is you gotta have
that personality and I don't know I
don't know if it I don't know if he does
you don't know if Roger says I don't
know if he has that personality of like
that Tom Brady like I'm a world beater
personality I'm Tom Brady has a I am
going to beat everybody no matter what
like a and I think he has it in his head
and his branding it's who he is I don't
know if Aaron Rodgers seems like the
type of guy seems more like me I'm not
that guy
I wouldn't be the guy to land a
franchise quarterback on I wouldn't be
it even if I had the most town the world
to be like I just don't I just want to
go boom sometimes okay you could play
the stoner buddy of the star quarterback
is what you could do yes I'd be I'd be
the world's worst I'd be ever Aaron
Rodgers worst influence I know you
didn't come in to promote overlord but
you're getting great reviews
with the role there yeah it's it's it's
great you know it's like it's a really
fun movie it's it's got zombies in it
but you have to now everybody it's a
really different take in a world war ii
film it's a blast i think that like it's
worth your 13 14 bucks or whatever like
to go see a movie you don't feel like he
got ripped off and yeah i love it i
think it's really fun what else was I
gonna ask you I was gonna
what was it Paul II that I was I was
gonna ask you about country music though
I know you're a big ol Simpsons big big
sergel's big part of my life
yes Oh Sarah is my favorite song oh
really
yes it's a great jewel Simpson can can
he's different he's different he's not
your typical Nashville country no he he
like in my job I think and everybody's
in your job and my job it's all very
similar they all have similarities that
like I think run through the the the
jeans of the job you do it your own way
and you find out how good you are
by doing it your own way and if it's and
and that's the only way that you can
really get good at anything right it's I
think it's really the only way it's good
at hockey it's the only way good at this
and circle Simpson to me has a way of
speaking to music fans and and going
like flipping them off at the same time
embracing them with a hug and I to me it
said I love Ashley have a fun Easter
little Simpson story I was I was going
fishing in Colorado we go we spent half
the year in Colorado as much as we can
my brother was living there
we're going fly-fishing we're coming
back at like eight nine o'clock it's
getting dark brace for impact is a song
that I've always liked skip over and
it's like I listened to like you know
another song it came on and I was like
yeah I'll stay on it the back road to
our house is very dark brace from impact
comes on like 15 seconds later and elk
appears in front of my truck like just
like boom didn't have time to put the
brakes on and brace for impact
killed it and then we got my brother and
I put it in the back of the truck I'm
actually like ate it we feel dressed it
and we eat yeah but that could be the
music video he's more about love and
connecting and not like as much like
carnage and death well good luck with
the acting career thanks man thank you
thank you thank you for being a fem he's
a white Russell Overlord is in theaters
now also he's in large 49 on demand
thank you for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]